[Music]
the kiss of the town of chiaravalle
makers lodo waldman shelf
[Music]
let's start
we are the masters it helps and from cremona
there are 169 of us and there are many of us
already paying and onida from cremona master of italy
this started a long
time ago  liked th century with
the invention of violin when origin
violin arrival of stradivari loved
ivan neri and why stradivari loved
guarneri very famous that this is the
world we continue this decade
[Music]
my name is benedikter friedman and i am the
size in cremona i do  the very few
instruments a year will be among the 78
giulini I put my heart and soul into it
and therefore consequently they have a
fairly high price abc the absence in the
city you can find instruments perhaps from
8,000 maybe 30,000 there is magic there is magic
in this city
[Music]
I'm stefano conia I've been a luthier in
Cremona since 1972 they're all made in a
contradiction with traditional tools and materials
and each instrument is  a
story of whether they have some magic
inside but it's my whole life
revolves around violin making i believe that
[music]
i couldn't have done anything
else
i believe that for me the existence
[music]